Robert,
thank you for being here.
We're happy to have you.
Um,
so as we just learned in the video,
food and security is very personal to you.
Can you talk more about that?
Sure.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
by parents were Korean,
from South Korea and they essentially moved over,
uh,
without really knowing any English.
And so my dad was a civil engineer and my mom was a banker.
Uh,
but when they came over to the states,
they really didn't matter because they didn't know any English.
And,
um,
so I remember times when we just,
you know,
a one huge bowl ramen for a meal for the whole day because that was pretty much
it.
Um,
and you know,
as I mentioned in the video that I get it,
you just think that's going wall and knew just kind of live with bed.
But,
um,
it was to the point where I just hated ramen cause,
uh,
you would just have so much.
But you know,
I grew up with kind of that kind of environment and my parents were always
telling me about how,
you know,
uh,
any food that you,
I'm sure people have the same experience in terms of,
you know,
stories that they're told.
But I was told that any food that I would waste would basically have to be eaten
in my afterlife all at once.
So,
so,
um,
you know,
I kind of grew up with the values of,
never wasting food and,
and really cherishing food whenever we had it.
So,
yeah.
Okay,
cool.
So now,
and you want to see an on hero award and you're on Forbes 30 under 30 social
entrepreneurs,
Leicester parents was to be very brand.
Um,
so what prompted you,
you left a very secure job in finance and you started RLC.
What,
what prompted that?
Oh man,
so many things.
I think because the two issues were so close to me and so personal,
I think,
um,
having the opportunity to kind of give back in this way,
uh,
in such a direct and common sense,
way and efficient way and the opportunity to scale a solution,
uh,
that,
you know,
was,
was such a huge problem.
Food,
waste and hunger and all these different kind of facets of those two things.
And,
you know,
while I was working at your firm,
Morgan,
I kind of compared my time of how much time I was spending,
you know,
what impact that had I should Morgan,
and the same amount of time and impact it would have at rescuing electric
cuisine.
I was just two,
two worlds apart and I just couldn't kind of,
um,
you know,
take it anymore and then wants to do something more meaningful with,
with my time and had an outlet to do it.
So I took the opportunity,
took the risk and uh,
yeah,
it was,
it was great.
The risk analyst we took over.
It's great.
Thank you.
Um,
so,
okay,
so what was the process of starting RLC?
Yeah.
So starting Rlc,
uh,
pretty much came,
from,
uh,
way back into college.
So during college was when I came across the of food rescue.
Um,
there was a club that brought leftover dining hall food to homeless shelters,
calls two birds,
one stone and Nyu and Nyu.
And it basically kind of opened my eyes to food rescue as a concept and to the
fact that food can be donated and that there's so much excess food.
Um,
so we were basically,
uh,
you know,
a bunch of us for a couple of friends and I were a kind of executive board
members of that club and kind of expanded it throughout the four years of Nyu
because it started out as just one kind of dining hall,
too,
one homeless shelter.
Uh,
but eventually you kind of,
uh,
under our leadership we're able to grow it out to all the difference,
a dining halls and basically growing up.
Um,
and that kind of opened my eyes to the fact that it's not just dining halls,
it's also restaurants and different food businesses that can donate their food.
And that there's such a huge need at homeless shelters.
Um,
and so that kind of first experience paved the way for kind of the first inkling
of an idea of,
of RLC add two birds,
one stone.
We kind of did everything on like a Google spreadsheet or core night.
Yeah.
Coordinating all these different volunteers and things like that.
But we had this dream of having a automated system that would connect excess
food to homeless shelters and have volunteers be the solution because during
college years we had the time to actually do a bunch of research and figure out
that,
you know,
solutions to food rescue in terms of food rescue existed and had a really great
impact in terms of great work of city harvest and food bank and things like
that.
But there were a little bit of a gap of how much,
uh,
you know,
food there was out there versus what they could pick up.
And so we wanted to basically tackle that specific gap and an operating that
niche with the model that we kind of learned and perfected during the college
years.
And so we took all of that.
It's kind of together and then entered into a venture competition,
uh,
ended up winning some seed money and,
pretty much launched it from there and kept on going.
All right,
cool.
Okay.
So what's the biggest challenge that you've faced as a social enterprise?
There's,
there's just so many.
Um,
I think in general,
I think the,
the kind of uncertainty is the biggest challenge is challenging aspect.
Um,
you know,
there's no way to kind of project in terms of how many new food donors are going
to bring on board,
how much pounds of food we're going to be able to bring on board.
But you know,
you kind of,
uh,
rely on,
um,
the,
the different,
uh,
you know,
aspects that you can rely on life that,
how much time you've put in,
how much effort you put in,
how many,
you know,
volunteers you can,
uh,
kind of corral to the cause and,
and you're basically a see what happens.
Um,
you know,
because of how local it is and how small it is.
It,
you know,
it's,
it's sometimes outsize in terms of the expectations of what you would do.
Thank you.
Get out of it.
But,
uh,
it turns out to be really good sometimes.
So,
uh,
I would say like,
you know,
just that,
unsure if he is like the biggest,
biggest challenge.
Cool.
Okay.
So let's talk about food waste,
which is astounding in this country.
Um,
we heard a few stats in the video,
like since you're the expert,
I would love for you to talk more about all of your wisdom on sure.
Yeah.
I,
I think,
um,
yeah,
when you think about food waste,
it,
you know,
it's just food waste.
But when you think about the different facets of what that means,
it's kind of mind blowing because it's not just about food waste,
it,
it's,
it's about the environmental impact of that food waste,
a,
the moral implications,
uh,
what that food,
you know,
has a potential to do a,
as long as you know,
the,
the actual economic impact of that.
So on kind of the environmental issue,
people don't really know that food waste is,
is one of the largest,
if not the largest component of a solid waste in the waste stream.
And actually lands in landfills where it basically contributes to carbon
emissions through a methane gases,
which was actually 20 times worse than carbon dioxide.
And if you take food waste as a kind of a global emitter of carbon emissions,
um,
and take it out as if it's like a country,
it would rank third right after us and China.
So just as a kind of environmental issue after the fact of wasting food,
it's a huge kind of issue.
Uh,
but even,
you know,
kind of going before that supply chain of actually wasting the food,
the amount of land amount of,
you know,
natural resources you use to grow that food is all wasted as well to grow the
food that we all eat in this country,
we use half the US land,
80% of the u s freshwater,
10% of the US energy budget is used to transport that food and trucks and supply
chain and things like that.
So,
you know,
all of that is wasted when your waste 40% of the food that you're producing.
So,
uh,
it's an environmental impact on both sides.
And so it's a,
you know,
when you combine those things,
it's a huge,
huge,
uh,
non negligible amount.
And that's just the environmental side.
I mean there's,
there's kind of whole,
like there's a whole bunch of studies and things like that and I think there
needs to be more studies on the environmental impact of food waste.
But the NRDC does a really great job,
uh,
of,
of kind of,
you know,
telling people about the issue of food waste.
And one of the other things that they mentioned obviously is the fact that,
um,
you know,
it's,
there's potential all food waste is,
is huge.
Um,
it's $165 billion problem in the U S I mean,
it's obviously,
you know,
an economic issue.
People are wasted or buying food from the supermarkets and then wasting it.
You might as well just not by 40% and know 64% of the food that you're buying at
the supermarket.
So,
um,
it's a huge kind of economic costs as well.
Obviously the US energy budget and things like that,
like that's our taxes going into food.
That's like going to be wasted like corn subsidies for corn or like why,
why do we do that?
Uh,
it's,
it's a huge,
yeah,
it's a huge kind of,
you know,
kind of complex issue and an implication implications that people don't really
think about.
When you think about it on deeper level,
obviously,
you know,
along the lines of potential food waste,
the,
the food that's actually going to waste,
I'll fucking see you can feed people so people,
uh,
can be fed with that and,
and,
and what's more important than kind of feeding people that are,
that are,
you know,
hungry and need that food if you're going to be wasting it.
And you know,
when you think about the flip side to that equation of kind of food waste and
hunger,
like 49 million Americans are food insecure.
And that,
I mentioned the video.
Like,
if you think about the nutritional,
and obviously poverty is a multifaceted issue as well,
and it's not just nutrition,
but if you think about just nutrition,
reducing the 30% of,
uh,
of the wasted food and bringing that directly to the people who are food
insecure would eliminate hunger,
which means that there's still two thirds of kind of food waste leftover that
needs to be reduced as well,
which is why there's,
you know,
the food waste hierarchy of reducing it on source and then feeding people,
feeding animals,
composting,
and then lastly landfill.
But,
you know,
I'm kind of going on and on about weight,
it's,
it's just so much.
It's so much.
Yeah.
And,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a huge,
huge issue.
So how do,
how do we compare it to other countries?
The U S uh,
you know,
uh,
throws out a lot.
Uh,
the average,
uh,
that,
that people say is 40% going through reports on the kind of worldwide level.
We waste about 30% of the food that we produce in the world.
Uh,
it's,
it's a lot.
It's a lot.
And,
um,
us is obviously a little bit worse.
Um,
but it's interesting because the US obviously as a developed con,
you know,
one of the developed nations,
uh,
it seems to waste a lot more food on and kind of our end on the consumer end,
which means there's a lot of education that needs to happen in terms of,
you know,
recognizing that food waste is a problem,
but also doing something about it,
uh,
and doing easy things,
that can be,
you know,
seep simply implemented in all of our lives.
Um,
but yeah,
in terms of like developing nations that a lot of their food waste is happening
on the agriculture,
on the,
on the kind of earliest side of the supply chain because they don't have the
technology or they don't have the resources to kind of implement those kinds of
systems that they have in the u s so,
uh,
it's,
it's a shame because,
I mean,
obviously the story that,
that I just mentioned about kind of having enough nutrition in the u s is the
same.
It's,
it's parallel across the world as well for in the world.
If we reduced just one third of the food that we have going waste,
that could be easily enough to eliminate food insecurity in the world.
So,
you know,
we talked about kind of overpopulation and like,
the,
the fear of,
you know,
feeding everyone and things like that,
but no one's thinking about why not reduce the food waste that we have going on
to solve that problem.
I mean,
like,
we don't have to increase production.
We can just be more efficient with the food that we're already producing.
Um,
but,
but yeah,
that's,
you know,
I think overall people are becoming more and more kind of aware of the issue
and,
um,
uh,
I'm glad that people are starting to pay attention.
So,
yeah.
So is it,
is food waste,
is it getting better?
Is it getting worse?
Is it sort of sounds the same?
I think there's not as much data as there needs to be in terms of a kind of
measurement and things like that.
And I think,
uh,
even more granular reports need to be,
published in terms of where specifically in the supply chain food is being
wasted.
But in general,
it seems like the problem with food base is becoming more and more of a
mainstream kind of issue that people are caring about.
Just in terms of,
you know,
the sheer number of articles and,
and tension that people are putting on food waste has been increasing in the
past,
you know,
three to four years.
We're lucky in that we used,
we just started in 2013 and it's been a huge kind of increase in the level of
attention that people are putting into food waste.
So we do believe that,
you know,
it's getting better,
but there's still obviously a lot of work to be done.
Yeah.
Okay.
So you've started RLC,
RLC solving the problem,
how it,
how is it different than other organizations?
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty much the number one question we always get.
Um,
but,
um,
we started it in 2013 because as I mentioned a little bit earlier,
uh,
we,
we started to notice that there was a kind of a gap or niche,
uh,
and do food rescue space.
And when we kind of started thinking about Kinda outside the board of Nyu and
how food rescue can be applied,
we did a lot of research into kind of city,
city harvest and food bank and even as hard as harvest in Australia and things
like that to figure out what solutions already exist in our,
what was happening,
what was working.
And so we,
uh,
realized that at least for New York City,
the current solutions typically had a minimum pound requirement way there with
Nahko by,
uh,
for food that was under a certain number of pounds.
Um,
so we decided to your essentially target that specific gap that,
that niche market and essentially,
uh,
kind of use our solution to that problem.
So,
you know,
we like to think of ourselves as different in terms of that minimum pound
requirement because we don't have one.
But also in the fact that we use a kind of technology driven process by using a
web application called on Ruby and rails that basically allows people to kind of
sign up online for any pickup they do want and crowdsource that transportation
problem,
that distribution problem between the excess food and the hungry.
So,
um,
yeah,
there's a whole bunch of other kinds of things that we,
you know,
I think one of the other ways we're different in that is that we are much more
scalable and that we have this kind of platform that can just be kind of
basically,
you know,
put to use in different geographic areas,
not just New York City.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
in other models do,
you may have to actually own trucks and own trucks and operate trucks and diff
each different city that you're there,
you're running in.
So we don't have that kind of,
you know,
issue.
So,
okay.
So with RLC,
there's sort of,
there's three parties.
You have a,
a food partner or a donor,
you have the volunteers and then you have the shelter.
So,
if I'm a food partner,
what does,
what does that look like?
Yeah,
for food donor,
we try and make it as easy as possible because there's a,
you know,
it's,
it's sometimes difficult for food donors to kind of feel comfortable about
donating food and there's always so many sigmas and myths around,
you know,
donate food.
Um,
so we try to make it as easy as possible and we kind of cater to,
uh,
the,
food donors needs.
So,
um,
as a food donor would,
when the partner with RLC diff there first ask pretty much when they throw out
their food and I worked frequency.
Uh,
so for example,
just thinking about any coffee shop a day may have pastries and muffins at the
end of the night that they,
that they throw out when they're closing out for,
for both,
for the four day.
And so they can tell us,
hey,
you know,
we,
we actually have these muffins and pastries that we throw out every single night
at 9:00 PM when we close a,
and what we can do is essentially,
basically,
you know,
ensure that we're there at that time every single day,
uh,
and,
make it super easy for them.
Instead of throwing it out into like a trash bag,
just put it into a different container that they can actually donate.
Um,
we do the transportation,
we do all the kind of paperwork and things like that for them,
uh,
and make it super easy for them to,
you know,
feel the impact and,
and understand that their food is going to the Hungary without actually doing
that much work.
Uh,
you mentioned there's,
there's myths about donating food.
So you often hear that it's illegal to donate food.
You can't do it.
And which is why,
you know,
restaurants throw it out.
But that's not necessarily true,
especially,
yeah.
I'll,
can you talk more about that?
Yeah.
The number one kind of pushback we get from restaurants and other food
businesses is that it's illegal.
Um,
which is unfortunately a,
you know,
just widespread for some reason.
Um,
w there's a Bill Emerson Good Samaritan Act of 1996 that's a federal law that
basically protects all food donors from legal liability.
Uh,
you know,
except in the case of gross negligence,
which is basically extreme carelessness.
So,
you know,
as long as they're adhering to all the food safety standards and ensuring that
they are,
you know,
a licensed food vendor and they know how to handle food and doing any food in
the right way,
um,
there's an old legal by liability.
Um,
of course,
you know,
if,
if they throw the food on the ground and then donate,
that's obviously not,
you know,
the,
the same thing.
But the federal law,
um,
you know,
existed since 1996 but,
uh,
all 50 states,
I've also passed state versions of that same exact guess.
Mentoring.
All of the,
in some cases is actually helping to provide even more additional protections
for food donors.
So,
um,
it's,
it's kind of insane too to hear sometimes from restaurants,
uh,
light.
They heard that,
you know,
Mcdonald's got sued for,
for some reason or another about food insecurity and people being sick off of
that,
a food that they donated.
And,
uh,
there's,
there's no legal,
you know,
case there's nothing in the kind of case record about that.
Uh,
so it's just,
it's just myths and you know,
people have been doing food rescue for her,
you know,
35,
40 years now.
Um,
and,
and you know,
as long as we are all each hearing to the same food safety standards in ensuring
that the food is safe,
food can be donated and can be completely fine.
So,
um,
yeah,
I think that's the number one kind of education point that that needs to kind of
happen for people to really start understanding that,
you know,
licensed food vendors,
people that are understanding,
you know,
people that can actually prepare the food correctly and safely can donate that
food.
Oh yeah.
Good to know.
Yeah.
Um,
so it's so great.
You have restaurants that donate the food.
Um,
do you report back any data,
you know,
letting them know this is how much you're wasting.
Can you talk about that?
Yeah.
So one of the kinds of benefits that we provide for restaurants,
uh,
is the data piece because,
um,
the,
there's a hierarchy of kind of what food waste should go to.
I haven't mentioned it a little bit.
Um,
the,
the kind of number one thing is to reduce it from the get go.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
for that,
it pretty much is,
uh,
thinking about creative ways to use excess food and things like that.
Uh,
or just just from the,
from the very production of it just don't produce that.
Um,
and so we provide monthly,
uh,
data in terms of days and number of pounds on how much food is being donated and
thus would have been wasted if they didn't work with us.
Uh,
and what that allows the partners to do is essentially kind of analyze that data
and see,
oh,
hey,
um,
you know,
I did not expect that much food to be going to waste.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of partners that we've worked with initially that has given us
estimates like,
oh yeah,
it's going to be about 40 pounds.
And it turns out not to be 40 pounds for the first two or three weeks,
turns out to be like over a hundred pounds.
And that's because they're just not measuring it.
And you know,
just like any KPI,
you're not,
if you're not measuring it,
you can't do anything about it.
Right.
And so,
you know,
basically having that monthly data allows them to do,
not just,
you know,
looking at and measuring out food waste data,
but also thinking about,
oh hey,
like every Monday or every weekend and we seem to have much food than food
waste.
And then,
you know,
other days and they can use that,
internalize that and basically reduce it on their own.
Cool.
It's a big Lee,
you know,
food donors want to obviously,
keep every single sale that they have.
So there's always going to be a little bit of food that is going to go to waste.
But we typically see like the numbers kind of,
you know,
start,
come down and plateau over time.
Um,
and that's why I wanted the kind of key things that we like to do is ensure
that,
you know,
we're measuring our food waste in terms of our success metrics,
but also keeping in mind that we don't want necessarily have more pounds of
food.
We keep,
we retain our kind of main KPI and may main kind of success measure as a number
of partners.
Um,
because that's the real kind of measures yes.
Uh,
in,
in terms of what we're thinking.
Cool.
So before we get to volunteers,
let's talk about,
so the shelters or the food recipients,
what does it look like for them?
Yeah,
so for the food Vince,
they're typically a homeless shelters,
soup kitchens,
food pantries,
community centers,
things like that,
license there,
five,
one C,
three a nonprofit authorizations.
And typically,
um,
what happens is after we find a,
uh,
homeless,
a restaurant partner that has a certain number of pounds of food and they give
us an equitation of like what type of fluid is going to go to waste.
And things like that and can be donated.
Um,
we go and match that up.
Uh,
we have great,
wonderful staff that help us do this and they basically help match,
um,
the,
the food to what food is needed at the homeless shelters,
soup kitchens and food pantries.
Um,
and that way it can be a regular recurring,
um,
food item that can basically offset the food that's,
you know,
that they would normally buy.
So,
um,
being an expected,
they know how much,
you know,
typically on average is going to be a,
and essentially they can take that out of the food budget.
Um,
and so,
uh,
that kind of partnership,
really starts with that food donor.
And,
and,
um,
on the food recipient side,
they receive it.
They give us a receipt that basically helps us measure the number of pounds.
Uh,
and how many,
you know,
that,
that basically goes back to the food donor and,
uh,
helps us maintain our records.
Kurtz.
So for the shelters there,
their goal is probably that they would never have to buy food.
That's the goal for them because they still do.
They still do.
They still do it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's insane.
There's this,
there's just so much food out there.
Um,
but you know,
it's,
it's always about the right type of food because different homeless shelters
have different requirements because they do different services,
right?
It's like some of them do just breakfast or it's something to do just dinner.
And so,
you know,
bringing a bunch of bagels to like solid on that just does dinner's not helpful.
Uh,
so it's just making that matching and then that's kind of,
you know,
uh,
where,
um,
we can,
you know,
make that a matching matching happen.
Cool.
Um,
okay,
so let's talk about volunteers because without
volunteers,
the organization doesn't really run.
Yeah,
I mean answers rather reasons,
but yeah.
Um,
so,
so what does it look like if you are a volunteer?
If you sign up to volunteer?
So anyone can go online and sign up to volunteer at screen,
left laughter cuisine.
Uh,
it's just www.rescuingleftoverlosing.org/calendar.
And there's basically a list of all the events that we have in,
in your region.
And essentially,
um,
the,
uh,
kind of events are listed,
events were,
rescues are listed as in chronological order and in different locations within
your region.
So for example,
in New York City,
uh,
there's like Fidei,
there's midtown,
there's,
you know,
upper west side,
upper east side,
and essentially people can filter down and looking at,
look on a map view as well and figure out what time and uh,
location they're available.
And to help out these pickups are a volunteer opportunities that are really easy
to kind of fit into your schedule because it's just 30 minutes of your time to
an hour.
So you can do it easily on her way to work on your way between classes or
between,
you know,
Jim and other things or in places.
Yeah.
Uh,
and you essentially can,
uh,
help make direct impact because you're gonna actually see after you sign up,
you'll get,
you know,
automated confirmation emails and all this and you'll get the contact
information of the person who's going to be leading your event.
And once you meet with everyone,
um,
you can actually see the actual food that's about to go to waste restaurants
cleaning off.
You get to see the Lumen Vinton's or bags and things like that.
And you can actually rescue that and walk it over.
Um,
sometimes,
you know,
uh,
will be 15 minutes walking.
Sometimes it'll be five minutes of walking.
Sometimes it would be like,
you know,
a little bit more,
25 minutes of walking,
but it'll be within that neighborhood,
same neighborhood.
And that's kind of what I love about the model is just local.
You know,
it's just local restaurants helping local homeless shelters with local
volunteers.
Um,
and that's it.
They drop it off,
they get the receipt and they upload it online through the application and,
uh,
and,
and that's it.
They made that impacted.
They help.
They can see the people,
the line of people outside the homeless shelter that's going to be fed with that
food.
So it's immediate.
It's sad.
Um,
you know,
impact that,
that they get a c.
So,
uh,
for a volunteer it's typically super easy.
Uh,
if people want to get even more involved,
it can be a lead rescue,
which like yourself
and people can lead on a,
on a weekly basis and actually help lead other volunteers,
uh,
and kind of,
you know,
take them through the route,
um,
and,
and be,
you know,
kind of responsible for that route.
Um,
so yeah,
there's,
there's a lot of ways to kind of help out in nearby
[inaudible].
Yeah.
I found,
you know,
I am a volunteer.
I volunteer every week with the organization and it's exactly what you said,
it's just very,
very simple.
Um,
I,
you on volunteer match,
which was,
you know,
which is where every,
volunteer opportunities,
let's say.
And um,
you know,
I,
I just,
I couldn't believe it was,
it was that simple.
And I think for people with busy schedules like all of us,
um,
it's,
it really is perfect and it's also a great way to get exercise to bring your
friends and do it.
Everyone's trying to,
you know,
knock,
say,
you know,
save money and not go to the bar at night,
bring them to,
uh,
bring them to a shift.
Yeah.
And it truly is 30,
30 minutes to an hour door to door to door.
Um,
but yeah,
to bring the food in and to walking into a shelter and to see the people who are
going to eat it right there is,
is,
it's just a wonderful,
it's,
it's what I love about RLC with other organizations.
I,
I think there's a,
you know,
long orientation process and,
um,
you know,
a waitlist and this is just click,
sign up,
show up and just kind of kind of do it.
Very,
very simple.
Yeah.
Couldn't believe it was that simple.
We tried to make it easy because,
you know,
we,
we really need as many people to help with this problem because,
um,
you know,
food waste is happening literally everywhere around us.
And,
uh,
you know,
we're all agents of,
people were just moving all the time.
And if we were moving with excess food and dropping off while we're going to
places,
it would just make it so much easier.
We could,
we could solve this problem.
So,
uh,
we didn't want that to be a barrier and a,
we wanted to give the power to the people to basically make a difference in
this,
in this problem.
Um,
but of course there is,
you know,
the lead rescue is to make sure that people are not stealing the fruit and the
fruit.
Yeah.
But,
but,
you know,
the lead rescuers are kind of,
the,
you know,
all the volunteers are kind of the crux of this model.
So.
And so,
um,
so you've expanded,
so you started in New York City and you've expanded to how many cities now?
1616 cities around the u s correct.
How has,
how has that expansion and you know,
what are the
siding?
I mean,
it's,
it's a lot of work.
Um,
you know,
it's,
it's exciting to see that,
you know,
it's not just New York City because New York City is such a unique city.
We were started here,
we're headquartered here,
but,
um,
it's,
uh,
yeah,
it's very different in other branches.
In New York City you can walk because there are homeless shelters and kitchens,
like literally,
you know,
15 minutes,
20 minutes away on foot from places,
but,
um,
and you'll never know him.
Um,
and,
but in places like,
you know,
other cities,
any other city,
uh,
you'll have to drive.
And,
um,
we,
you know,
we had to kind of figure out a,
what's the right model to kind of tweets to tweet the technology a little bit to
accommodate for that and things like that.
Um,
but it's working out really well.
So,
um,
it's also very different in terms of,
you know,
the types of food businesses that are outside of New York City.
A lot of the pounds of food that we get are sometimes larger and,
um,
but,
but it's deciding w currently are working on a lot of the kind of lower end of
the supply chain in terms of,
you know,
restaurants and,
um,
retail businesses.
But,
uh,
eventually,
you know,
obviously the food waste problem is so complex that,
we want to help out in any,
you know,
with the same technology and the same system help out with any level of the
supply chain,
wherever access food is happening.
So,
uh,
it's exciting,
but you know,
obviously a lot of,
yeah,
a lot of things to kind of consider.
Great.
If anyone has any questions,
you can line up at the mics in the center or the Isles and um,
I'll keep asking you questions.
Okay.
So,
um,
okay,
so,
so what,
what can people do?
Of course they can volunteer,
um,
what,
you know,
what other types of things do you need help with?
I believe you got a grant last year.
Um,
you know,
what,
what is your organization?
Yeah.
So,
so yeah,
last year from,
we actually got a grant from Google,
which was really amazing.
Uh,
and thanks again for that.
I mean,
um,
but you know,
it helped us develop our technology.
Uh,
and,
and at the crux of it,
this is a technology driven a system.
Without steering analogy,
we would have to have like five more staff members that are coordinating and
sending emails and sending reminder emails and things like that.
Um,
but you know,
with this technology we're able to kind of scale it up and be much more
efficient.
So in terms of ways that people get help,
there's just,
there's so many,
right?
I mean,
um,
uh,
on the most basic level,
like you can give time,
you can give resources,
you can give,
um,
you know,
contacts and there's like that.
So on,
on the time side,
obviously you can sign up as a regular volunteer and sign up whenever you want,
whenever you're available.
Um,
and on,
you know,
if you want to invest even more time,
it can be a lead rescue where you can be a core risky.
We were doing 10 times a week,
you can be,
you know,
you can help us out in the office and you know,
with your skill sets and things like that.
Um,
and then on the resources side,
you know,
obviously we're a five one c three nonprofit organization and so we basically
depend on,
uh,
you know,
monetary donation is to continue to grow and expand.
We do have a operations that allow us to kind of,
you know,
organically grow in terms of,
uh,
having the operations covered by earned revenue.
So any donations that people make are contributing directly to the growth,
uh,
which is,
which is really why we've been able to expand so quickly over the past few
years.
Um,
so like for example,
last year we doubled the year before that we couldn't top old.
Uh,
so,
you know,
we were able to do this because we have,
the,
the kind of model that we can continue to be able to be sustainable.
Um,
and then on kind of the,
the contact side,
I mean,
we are a,
an organization that works with a lot of different parties.
Um,
restaurants,
catering companies,
a farms,
wholesalers,
retailers.
There's so many different food businesses,
food kind of a related organizations.
There's food waste everywhere.
When it thinks the places that people don't even think about,
uh,
like stadiums,
fashion shoots,
you know,
the photo shoots,
like it's just literally everywhere.
It's not just the restaurants and things like that.
So,
um,
contacts that people have to these people that we can basically,
you know,
set up a relationship and make it really easy to donate their food is ideal.
Um,
and,
and yeah,
and obviously on the homeless shelter side,
if people have contacts to places where we can help,
you know,
partner with to distribute the fear,
um,
you know,
that's a huge help as well.
So yeah,
lots of ways,
but I would say number one,
just volunteer time,
go onto our website and sign up online and so fun.
Yeah,
you can see the people.
yeah.
Great Way to meet people.
It really is.
Yeah.
We have a question over here.
Hi.
So I think the word that you guys do is amazing and also it's in an area I don't
know that much about.
And so I learned a lot today.
Thank you.
I kind of had a question around,
um,
you know,
food insecurity is not a problem where,
like medicine or something where like a person needs a one time treatment and
then you fixed them.
It's,
you know,
you need food every single day.
And so it is a structural problem.
And I was wondering if you could talk a little bit about some of the stuff you
mentioned earlier about like,
do cities have programs where they do some food waste pickups and stuff for
shelters and already,
or is that an area where there's room for you to expand from the volunteer and
nonprofit side to like policy advocacy at all?
Yeah,
that's a really good question.
Um,
there,
there's a bunch of different levels to that question,
but,
uh,
in terms of what RLC is doing,
to kind of help with the food insecurity issue,
uh,
as I mentioned,
food insecurity and poverty in general is a really complex issue and nutrition
is just one piece of the problem.
Uh,
and,
and food waste is going to help contribute to the overall solution to that
problem.
And the way we see it is,
uh,
the amount of money that we can save the homeless shelters from buying food.
They can use that money to have much more longterm solutions like job skills,
trainings,
shelter and basic needs and things like that.
And we see ourselves as part of the solution to that problem.
So,
um,
you know,
in terms of policy and things like that,
we're really excited about kind of making sure that food rescue becomes more and
more mainstream and hopefully even required in the future.
Maybe,
um,
you know,
similar to like what's France doing if France is doing and things like that.
But,
uh,
it seems like that's a bit further away,
especially with current events.
But,
um,
it,
it seems like,
you know,
policy is something that's really important to do,
make this,
uh,
you know,
a requirement that make this,
uh,
at least,
you know,
much more mainstream,
uh,
across food business as a whole.
So,
uh,
hopefully that answers both parts.
The question.
Hmm.
Cool.
Hey,
thank you for coming on today.
You're obviously,
you know,
you found it here in New York and based,
um,
and you're talking about expanding to other cities and whatnot.
If somebody wanted to start this same kind of program in any other city and
still like going to your same brand and be part of your organization and your
resources,
like how would we do that?
Do you have like franchising committees or things?
Basically
kind of like a franchising,
but it's like for like a nonprofit.
So,
um,
but it's the same type of process.
We have a a badge application process that you go through a happy to,
um,
kind of,
uh,
you know,
give out that information.
Uh,
the,
the number one ways to go onto a website and contact us about the opportunity or
email us at Info at rescuing.
And leftover cuisine.org and essentially it's just a kind of,
um,
to create a branch in any area,
you just need to kind of,
uh,
have a certain number of,
you know,
people that are dedicated to the cause to,
to grow the branch and things like that.
Uh,
but yes,
we require,
uh,
you know,
the help from people that are local to understand the local environment,
um,
with and do the research of what exists and what's working,
what's not working in that specific area.
Because the worst thing that we can do is duplicate kind of effort that's
already happening.
Uh,
and,
and we,
we did a ton of research in the beginning to make sure that we weren't
duplicating efforts and we were targeting that niche market.
Um,
and so we would,
we would basically figuring out that together.
Um,
I'm curious,
you know,
you mentioned that what sets you apart from others is that you have this,
this,
um,
technology component.
Um,
if you had,
is there a bigger goal for the technology of,
of,
you know what,
yeah,
what does that,
what does that look like?
Yeah.
There's so much we can do.
I mean,
um,
currently it's 11
vocation code in Ruby on rails and we're trying to let kind of push towards a
progressive web application,
which I think actually is a Google thing.
Um,
but,
um,
what we would love to do is make this a more kind of mobile app type of
situation that it uses location settings that uses a push notifications and
things like that right now are you relying on texts and emails and things like
that,
but push notifications and location settings would be huge because,
uh,
as we scale,
as we have more and more restaurants and pickups that kind of,
you know,
randomly,
logistically in terms of a sheer number of volunteers and sheer number of
pickups that are happening,
there are going to be more opportunities of people kind of calling out or um,
you know,
not going to be able to make them advent and things like that.
And if we had the bobble capability to basically say,
hey,
you're in the area and you know,
have a push notification that goes in and ask those people to basically cover
that event,
that would basically like,
they'll be a huge game changer.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
there's,
there's so many other things we want to do with,
uh,
with those kinds of,
where the technology out there.
There's also,
um,
you know,
the whole transportation industry right now,
it's kind of going through the automated kind of transportation system going on.
And one of the things that want to,
and we're excited about,
uh,
trying to pilot is figuring out how that kind of automated drivers situation or
drones situation can be applied to food rescue because it totally can and could
be a great solution to applying technology to a age old to age old issues.
Um,
so yeah,
there's so much exciting things.
Yeah.
There,
there's a great potential there.
So,
so in a perfect world,
no food is wasted.
Yeah.
What happens to RLC?
Well,
that's,
see,
that's it.
That's the thing
because,
um,
you know,
I've always struggled with that.
I think it's also because of my background as a,
you know,
working at JP Morgan and for profit.
I think when I kind of went into the nonprofit space,
it was,
it was difficult to kind of have the right KPI.
And I mentioned that kind of number of partners was most important.
And one of the reasons why we consciously decided to go with a volunteer driven
model was so that we can scale up and down as needed.
If,
if the restaurant starts out 120 pounds,
we can have,
you know,
10 volunteers carrying 10 pounds,
12 pounds each.
But then if it goes down to 40 pounds and they're able to reduce it on,
on,
on site,
then we can just bring four pounds,
four volunteers.
Um,
and so the way we see it is we basically can use,
well,
whatever we have at our disposal in terms of volunteers to accommodate whatever
the cap is,
the capacity is required.
Uh,
but we're not reliant on it.
We're not looking to have a lot of pounds of food so that we can pair employees
that can,
you know,
like we want to be able to kind of remain nimble and kind of actually solve the
problem rather than kind of perpetuating,
right.
Yeah.
So,
yeah.
Any other questions?
All right.
Well if you have one call to action or one thing you'd like to leave with and
also if you could remind everyone of the website.
Yes.
Yeah,
that's of course.
So yeah,
with the number one thing is going onto a website I rescuing leftover
cuisine.org/calendar and signing up for your first pickup.
Yeah.
It's a really great way to kind of check us out.
Uh,
go on to the Lurie and figure out,
oh,
day three day,
all day,
every day,
seven days a week.
Um,
the video said I think 10 to midnight and now we do a pretty much like 8:00 AM
to like 2:00 AM so,
uh,
no excuse.
No.
But,
but yeah,
it's really,
it's really
great.
It's a really great way to how Robert,
thank you for coming.
Thank you so much for that.
Okay.
Awesome.